so this theater is a remarkable building
Philip chatzky whoo-hoo it's named after
and he was the donor who was right
behind building this also built
educational schools for technical
training for students that's what his
business was as if engineering graduate
from here that's what he went out and
made his money at in his career from
that I think he understood that you need
everything at your fingertips if you're
going to Train somebody will do you need
really good equipment you need
state-of-the-art technology you need an
embracing and warm environment for
actors to perform the scale of the
theater needs to be appropriate to young
voices and the scale of what we can do
production wise and this is really a
unique theater in America for that
activity it's just the right size for us
it has wonderful acoustics we've been
able through that Phillip chatzky
Educational Trust to upgrade nearly
every aspect of the theater as those
things fall do so we're about to recover
all the seats for example so we want to
keep it at what Phillip would have
wanted which is an impeccably kept
state-of-the-art facility to train young
artists so Phillip used to come to the
theater often when he was a student and
then when he graduated and was running
his business he would come and he was a
great patron the faculty knew him of the
period he would know the students he
would know each class coming out he used
to come and sit in this very chair so
this was where he was it's wonderful for
rows from the front and this is it's
lovely to think that I'm sitting with
maybe where Phillip Shaw ski sat looking
at his theater and his legacy which is
this great building